be talking about the Julian language how
many people in the room have ever used
Julia before none good okay so that then
the novice introduction level will be
good I'll start from assuming very
little language so very little knowledge
so there's several different ways you
can get started I this is a PI data
conference so probably most of you have
a Python anaconda type environment
already set up if you've been using your
ipython Jupiter notebook it actually
supports now now that it's called
Jupiter it supports Julia as an
alternate kernel language so it should
be pretty easy to get started there's
also this was recently migrated from it
used to be Julia Box org and now it's
Julia bucks comm but it's the same deal
if you don't want to install julia right
now it's a huge download but if you want
to just try this out in your browser you
go to julia box comm and you can use a
Google authentication sign-in with any
Gmail or anything and this will run a
hosted docker container just on Google
VM that will pop up in a few seconds a
hosted Jupiter notebook and console
environment so this is also a cool thing
you can do without needing to set
anything up or if you do want to install
it locally if you think you'll be using
it more than just for this depending on
how convinced you are Julia Lang org
slash downloads so we the stable release
version is going to be 0.4 0.6 something
like that we're about to do we're doing
a release candidate for our next version
right now but for the purpose of this
demo introduction there not going to be
too much of a difference that you'll
notice right away so I'd recommend going
with the stable version not all the
packages are totally updated right now
but if you use julia so the main basic
julia installation gives you a prompt
it'll run in your terminal it's a ripple
and you can install packages that way so
the the way to interface to your jupiter
notebook as you do PKG add
hi Julia using I Julia and then notebook
and that should fire up if it already
has Jupiter installed in your system it
should be able to find it hook into it
and not need to do too much else it
should create a new kernel profile for
the julia kernel and then locally you
can open it'll look familiar
but you'll be able to run julia kernel
backends okay so let me know if anyone
starts going through this process and
has any problems we've got tons of time
and it's not too many people in the room
ok so it's a PI data conference and I'm
not talking about Python but why why a
new language right Julia hasn't been
around for that long I was only released
open source in 2012 so you know you're
all it's a data PI data right so
presumably people have some sort of
numerical problem you want your computer
to help you solve you're writing code to
do beta analysis processing so sort of
my phrasing of this is you know you have
a problem to solve if somebody else has
solved a similar problem and is written
code and shared their code open source
you know we build our we use our tools
wisely we pick tools that are already
available to give us a head start it's
great you know use their code this
library is like numpy sai pi pandas
these are huge great resources to start
from to make your life easier so you
don't have to build everything from
scratch the issue is what if it's not
you know enough right you start with
what's available but then you need to do
more right is is it easy enough to use
does it perform well enough can you
understand it what if you need to add a
feature fix a bug right can you modify
the code to suit your particular use
case so conventionally you know if if
you're good if you're set then you know
thank the author fix a bug help out but
if not and I the the problem that julia
is sort of out to solve in conventional
tools especially classical python are
matlab these conventional environments
for doing numerical and scientific
computing is you have this two language
problem as we call it so this is just
sort of a
a quick snapshot of the github
repositories for python itself numpy and
Sai PI of what languages are they
written in so you know it's not the
greatest measurement this is I don't
exactly how github counts this can be a
little weird sometimes but you look at C
Python itself is 40 percent C numpy is
over half C Sai pi is a mix of Fortran
and C and C++ and none of n yeah so so
there's a lot of low-level nasty C code
that a lot of people don't want to be
writing in day-to-day or have to worry
about when things go wrong so you you
kind of have this user friendly code you
work with day to day that you want to
write it something nice and high-level
like Python but then when performance is
a problem you have to go down to
something lower level or there's this
great flowchart that this may look
familiar user name helgi Eichorn who
does astrodynamics but if people can
read this you know this is sort of a
decision tree of if you have Python code
and you want to make it faster you kind
of have to go through this you know as
it numerical code is it not numerical
code can you vectorize it write it a
numpy or try number does it work or
scythe on there's all these sort of
different tools you can use and a lot of
times you end up having to rewrite the
most performance critical parts in C so
what Julie is out to do is make that
unnecessary so you know Python numpy sy
PI these are all very mature projects
that have been around for a long time
but nowadays you know it's 2016 there's
a lot of advancement in technology
especially if you think about browsers a
lot of the development in making
javascript run
ridiculously quickly in your browser has
developed a lot of advanced compiler
technology just-in-time compilation
there's a lot of the LLVM compiler
framework which is also used by numba
and clang if you
compiled C code on a Mac any time in the
last few years it's using the LLVM
compiler framework which is open source
and a very very useful resource so using
a lot of these advanced these
technologies that are available now we
know how to make a dynamic language that
feels like Python run as quickly as if
you were writing code and C so this is
possible today and this is the goal of
Julia so if you go and look at the Julia
repository 2/3 of the code in Julia just
in that repository is in Julia itself so
you can write the standard library the
basic operations of the language in the
high-level language and still have it be
high performance so I'm gonna spend the
rest of the time in some notebooks so
the these notebooks I'm borrowing from a
professor named David Sanders who's done
a lot of really great tutorials and
trying to zoom in here but so these are
at github comm /dp Sanders and there's a
set of them so there is invitation to
Julia as one of them ok well I already
have them cloned but there's invitation
to Julia is one of them hands on Julia
is another and I think it is
intermediate Julianne yes ok so I've
already cloned all three of these but so
this is a very useful tutorial set of
notebooks they're all kind of he's been
developing these and giving tutorials
over the last several years so they're
pretty closely related to one another
but this is what I'm gonna be mostly
working from is sets of these notebooks
so we're okay so starting out this was
invitation to Julia part one so we're
gonna just start from a kind of
motivating example of let's do something
in this language called Julia that
people in the room have not used before
but are interested in finding out about
ok so this is your
your Jupiter notebook and let's just say
let's do Newton's method right basic
kind of calculus okay so the Julia
language should feel pretty familiar
there's nothing too crazy that will
we'll look out of out of left field if
you're used to Python or other MATLAB or
our other sort of standard dynamic
interpreted languages right so I'm gonna
set a variable X 0 another some nice
things that Julia the fact that it's
2016 and Unicode is standard now Python
3 has also done this now is you can use
Unicode in your variable names if you
like making them look pretty and look
like the math so in in Julia's repple
there's a convenient shortcut to
actually make these unicode symbols
easier to type so if you've ever written
a paper in LA tech there is you know the
backslash notation for how to get a lot
of these symbols right backslash you
know if you're writing in Greek
characters backslash alpha or backslash
Delta ok so julia has tab completion for
a lot of these standard mathematical
notations for superscripts and
subscripts with backslash right so you
can tab complete on on a lot of these
symbols ok so that's also a convenient
you know notation will make your code
look a little prettier as be part of
your identifier okay so in Julia Julia
is a dynamic language but it's also a
language in which you talk about types
so every value in julia has a type
associated with it so we were giving
these this x0 we were assigning it the
integer value of 4 which is if you're on
a 64-bit system is going to be
defaulting to a 64-bit integer okay so
now let's not just assign variables but
let's actually assign some functions so
the julia has a nice convenient
one-liner very much like the
mathematical syntax for defining a
function
saying f x equals x squared minus 2 and
the function itself I'll get more into
what this means this output of a generic
function with one method I'll get into
what that means but the f is a function
object so functions are first class
values they have a type associated with
them this will change but type of F is
function so you can also pass these
around so but if you want to call that F
on the x0 on the value three that I had
a fun assign to it earlier pretty
straightforward okay and so we're going
to be doing Newton's method as they're
sort of motivating example to start with
we're gonna use we're gonna need
derivatives of a function not just the
function but also its derivative and if
you like your mathematical notation you
might want to use prime for that but in
Julia prime is actually a special syntax
so prime like in MATLAB will be used for
matrix transposes so if you try to make
Prime on the left hand side that's
actually gonna be a syntax error but as
we were showing earlier with unicode
this is something that maybe you would
want to do and maybe you might consider
is too hard to read but Julie allows you
to do this you can use the Unicode Prime
character of doing backslash Prime and
autocomplete and that's actually a
distinct character so that can be part
of your identifier z' and doesn't have a
special syntactic meaning in julia so if
we've defined f prime as our derivative
function you could also do this with
super scripts right super scripts don't
actually have a mathematical operator
meaning to them you might think this
would mean squared but no it's just the
unicode character for superscript 2 so
this is actually the variable name is x
squared here but the right hand side the
value the syntax I'm taking X naught
squared okay right so one step of the
Newton of Newton's method starting from
three all right I take the initial
you minus the function divided by the
derivative okay
so that was step one and you'll notice
this is another sort of difference
between Python 2 and Python 3 of what do
you get when you divide two integers
right so Julia follows the Python 3
convention of any time you divide two
integer valued functions or integer
valued integer values it will give you a
floating-point result by default however
there is if you want integer division
you can still have it it's just spelled
differently so you can do div if you
really need integer division right so
div if you're dropping div five of two
is gonna be just dropping the remainder
okay so I've gotten I've wound up going
from integer valued inputs integer
valued functions but because of the
division this result was now a
floating-point okay so another thing to
notice that's going to be distinct from
Python is when you're doing integer
arithmetic it's going to be machine
integers so this is going to be as we
showed earlier it's an INT 64 an integer
raised to an integer power and there's a
function to look at the bit
representation of I took two to the 62
so you can see we have a 1 in the second
highest bit but if I then multiply that
by 2 it wraps around all right so this
is machine integer arithmetic it's going
to be modulo 2 ballistic it's gonna be
sign a signed integer right because I
multiplied by 2 the integer arithmetic
shifted to the left but that is actually
now the sign bit so I got the smallest
value you can also see this there's
functions for this called type min and
type max so this is the smallest value
of the type in 264 or the largest value
of the type in 64
is to to the 60 3-1 all right so that's
something to notice if and if you want a
arbitrary-precision
integer julia has that by default in the
standard library but you have to convert
to it you have to explicitly say I want
a big int type I want an arbitrary
precision integer all right so if I take
a big integer two and raise that to the
62nd power this is going to still be a
big int same value but then if I
multiply this value by two so this is
shorthand here right so Julia does
support the shorthand modification in
place one thing to note is this always
is exactly equivalent to writing this
right so anytime you were to see x equal
or plus equal it's going to just exactly
be equal to the operator at the left
hand side repeated so this is something
that's part of the syntax
so this is going to be a it's going to
be rebinding so it's going to be as if
you wrote so I'll show a raise soon but
if I had write an array Y as an array
and then I wanted to do
but now so Z is still one it's probably
clear if I
so if you've done an array you're
actually going to be rebinding right so
this is going to be exactly equivalent
to if you had written Y times 2 so the
left-hand side is actually going to be
creating a new array okay and one thing
to note is the big function right if you
take it this may look a little
misleading but it's it's actually just
doing the exact same thing that we do we
were doing earlier where to the 63 was
in the integer The Motley in the Machine
integer wraparound arithmetic so this is
actually wound up overflowing before I
converted it to a big integer so that's
something to note is that the where you
put the parentheses will matter in the
order of operations there right and with
arbitrary precision integers you can
start doing you know things that will
take a while and give very very long
very high precision integer arithmetic
numbers so this will use the underlying
GMP C library if anyone is familiar with
that but the nice thing is that julia
will give you these sort of high-level
interfaces to it so you don't have to
worry about wrapping this the C library
underneath right so this was a 19,000
digit integer there okay
mm-hmm
yes so the normal way would be using the
macro at time so that's the standard way
we in the default standard library we
don't actually have I think in Python
the time at macro or annotation or
whatever it is will by default run it
multiple times and give you an average
and a little bit of statistics we don't
have that in by default the time macro
the app time macro in julia will only
run things once so you will notice if
you were to run some big long-running
calculation the at time the first time
will actually include the compilation
time the second and third and fourth
time will reuse the already compiled
code Julia as I mentioned is
just-in-time compiled so the first time
you call something it might have some
compilation time overhead and the time
macro doesn't hide that from you okay so
in terms of iteration and loops right we
we had we were just dealing with simple
scalars so far we have julia has four
loops while loops standard control flow
that you would expect right so in Julia
Julia is not indentation sensitive we we
use end to mark the end of blocks which
can kind of help if you know if you're
in the not in the notebook if you want
to do a one-liner right if you want to
do for eye even one to five you can just
squeeze it all on one line if you really
feel like it the semicolons here are
necessary if it's all on one line just
to do mark where the expressions end but
here the you know we recommend if you're
writing code that you plan on reading
ever again you know indentation is for
humans there's a style guide but it's
not enforced by the language you can
still parse ugly code if you want okay
so one thing to note is that the
iteration variable I is actually only
defined inside the loop okay so I don't
have
a variable I after I've run this loop it
was available inside but it's scoped in
that way as a local variable okay so I
was using this the : notation I was
using one two five so that is a range
object alright so if I ask Julia what is
the type of that one to five object
so there's several built-in range types
that use the convenient : syntax to
create them one thing to note as you
probably know it as you probably saw is
that in Julia the ranges are closed
right so they're inclusive of the
endpoint so this goes with it's kind of
connected to the way in which you index
arrays often they go together Julia
takes the one indexing counting as if
you're counting you start the first
element of the array is 1 and the last
element of the array is n if it's n
elements so the ranges are are closed
okay so you can go from this this one to
five is a unit range object right and it
will it's gonna be a type that's defined
in Julia and it's also going to have
some fields I'll get into so this one
two five is going to be a unit range
object that will actually have a start
and a stop so this is going to be stored
compactly just in terms of its start
point and its end point so it won't
actually if you're if you've ever
written in MATLAB or are I think when
you do a for loop over a range it
actually constructs the dense vector of
every single element that it has to
visit just to know that I'm iterating
over a for loop
Julia uses an iteration protocol so this
one two five is an iterator and an
iterable object and you can convert that
into an array with the collect function
okay so if you want to take an iterator
and say give me an array of what each
successive element in that iterator
would have hell would have held you use
collects to do that okay so collect will
give you an array right and by default
the array is going to be a dense
possibly multi-dimensional array of
values and you'll notice the curly brace
syntax so that is a a type parameter
that is telling you what the element
type is so here because the start point
and the end point of this unit range
we're both 64-bit integers every element
in the array is a 64-bit integer so this
stores a lot this does a lot of the
essentially efficiency optimizations
that numpy does where numpy is able to
be efficient on homogeneous arrays where
every element is the same type in julia
that's just built into the default array
type you could have an array if you
start with just an empty array with just
brackets that doesn't have anything in
it then Julia doesn't know what the
element type is so that's going to be an
element type any and this will be much
more like a Python list right where any
element could be you could have a
strength the first element and then an
integer and a floating-point and it
would be heterogeneous okay but if
you're collecting a unit range of
integers then you're gonna get an array
of integers where the element type is
all the same okay right that was five
elements long right and we could also
you know construct arrays it'll look
pretty simply stand 'red using square
brackets and you can iterate over the
elements of an array so arrays are
iterable so you can use this in syntax
you could also sort you could also use
the equal sign so that either syntax is
accepted in a for loop I think if you
want to get into Unicode sometimes we
can use that this is not implemented yet
in julia 0.4 but in julia 0.5 it'll
accept this in a for loop if you want
to make your code look even more like
the math we do except that in a
containment right so I can say is is the
value for in the array W and I get yes
for is in the array right and I can also
do the Unicode version of that in for
loops yes right so in the for loop you
can but outside of the for loop
iteration specification you know if I
was to say for equals W know that that's
not right I can't assign to be integer
for so that's an error okay so now we
have loops and we have basic values so
we can actually do Newton's method
alright so we had the function f we had
F prime it's derivative we start from X
0 3 and we'll do ten steps we'll say X
new is the starting value minus its
value the function value over the
derivative and will print so println its
function that will print a set of values
you give to it followed by a new line if
you don't want the new line if you
wanted it all on one line you could do
print but that's a little hard to read
so we'll put in some line breaks with
println so that's gonna say the I value
the tab character backslash T if you're
the the escaping of the tab and then the
new value so I started the first step
after three X 0 is 3 X 1 is one point
eight three is we had seen and in 10
steps that converges pretty close to the
square root of two which is the one of
the roots of this function right but if
I were to give it another if I were to
give it negative 3 is the initial
condition you can see it's going to
converge to a different result
right so let's let's look at a variety
of initial conditions right so we'll say
this is another way of specifying ranges
here I'm saying the step of this range
all right so this is going to be a
floating-point range that starts at
negative five goes by one eight and goes
to five so that's gonna end up with 81
elements so yeah of course you know if
you're in your right if you're in your
notebook then tab-completion is very
useful the tap the julia repple also
supports a lot of these things too if I
wanted initial conditions equals so the
basic command prompt you don't have to
use hi Julia if you would rather work in
a basic prompt so the tab completion and
all these things also work there outside
of I Julia okay now or if I want so that
the default showing of an array you know
if you have an array of thousands and
thousands and thousands of elements you
don't want you don't want the spam of
every single element necessarily at
least not by default so it'll truncate
it'll show with some dot dot dot saying
that you know there's more elements in
here but I'm not going to show them all
- to save your output but if you want to
show them all you can do use the show
all function for that so that'll show
absolutely everything but in a one-line
form so this we had done is a different
type now all right so this is going to
be now a float range and the elements of
that org are going to be float64 okay
okay so in the curly braces that gives
you the parameter of this type okay so
if you want to make an array another way
to do this you can create an
uninitialized array using the similar
function
alright so initial conditions we had was
was a float range and we used collects
as one way of creating an array from it
another way would be similar which will
not copy the values it will just create
an uninitialized
empty container of the same size but the
values in it will be uninitialized
memory garbage so don't read from these
this is just for writing to so this is
whatever happened to be in memory it's
going to be different every time
you know a lot like if you were using c
malloc right you can't rely on on the
values that you get there it's just an
uninitialized container of a given size
okay
so there's some convenient iterators to
to do certain patterns so a one of these
is called enumerate so if you do a
numerate of an iterable object here this
float range how that works is that gives
you a counter and the value right so
it's the its equivalent to what I just
commented out here of saying for an
index j from 1 to the length of the
array of the of the iterator and then
saying at each iteration i want to take
the jace element of the iterator so
enumerate is just a convenient shorthand
for doing that
and it returns a tuple right so in
parentheses is a tuple of the index and
the value and I've you do destructuring
assignment on the left hand side so this
is the way of assigning multiple values
so I can say if I want a comma B equals
so this is something that I think James
is also mentioning is being some
extensions to this are relatively new in
Python 3 extending you know interesting
ways of doing multiple assignments and
destructuring
julia supports that as well through
tuples and enumerate yeah not on the
left-hand side or actually sometimes no
yeah so that will give you so not so not
always
I think the parentheses I find a little
more explicit sometimes but you can
leave them out when the context is clear
okay so if the parser is able to figure
out that that's exactly what you meant
then you can leave them out you mean if
I had a tuple of what do you unpack in
what way yeah yeah
so that is
so that is done with the the dot dot dot
right so that printed four and then five
okay so I have enumerate gives you the
tuple of the index and the value a
counter and the value which just saves
you a little bit of boilerplate
when that's a common iteration pattern
so now I'm writing into the array routes
right so we created this uninitialized
routes array that we were going to write
the results into and here we assign into
the J's element of the array with the
value that we go after here a hundred
iterations for Newton's method
yeah so you you do need to initialize it
as some size but if it's one dimensional
you are allowed to actually grow it but
you use a different syntax for that so
unlike in MATLAB if you were to write
beyond the end of an array MATLAB would
grow the array which is one of the
things that makes knowing what size an
array is going to be in an intermediate
iteration kind of complicated and I
think it will lint at you and warn you
if you do that if it's able to figure
out and tell you this is going to be
slow but if you want to grow an array in
gulia
so the way you would do that so you can
create so I was creating earlier an
empty array so this is an empty array of
any but you can create an array with a
particular element type by giving the
type to the left of the brackets so this
is going to be an empty array of
integers and then if I want to append an
element to the end of that array you use
push and there's a convention in giulia
where functions that end in an
exclamation point
this is really just a naming convention
but it's pretty common in julia to want
to do in-place operations so the
exclamation point is a convention that
means this is going to be mutating one
of its arguments in place usually the
first argument so here push is saying
that it's a it's a mutating operation so
the value that a has before is going to
be mutated after the function is called
it has side effects
it's it's at the end right so if I think
there is a way to append at the
beginning and I think that's called
unshifted empty I added six to the end I
added seven to the end and then I added
one to the beginning right but because I
declared the array as an integer if I
then want to append something that's not
an integer you'll actually get an
inexact error so Julia will not change
the element type of the array it will
give you an error if you try and put
something in it that doesn't fit but it
will try to convert right so if you try
to if you give it a floating-point
number but a floating-point number that
is exactly convertible to an integer it
will do the conversion to put it into
the integer array but it will give you
an inexact error if it's not exactly the
same value okay so we were discussing so
we're showing enumerate right so
enumerate of an integer an array of
integers and just looking at what that
successfully does it does the counter
one two three and then the values of the
iterable object that you give to an
Emery okay right and as I mentioned
tuples
so the parentheses another if you want a
tuple with only one element in it you
actually do need the comma to
disambiguate if you were to give just
the parentheses that's just the integer
3 in parentheses so it's a little bit
ambiguous with the 1 element tuple so a
single comma tells you tells you that
it's one element but the empty tuple is
just empty parentheses
okay all right so after we had done we
had that's all right so we hit assigned
the roots to all of the initial
conditions in that array and we saw
essentially for negative initial
conditions we wound up at negative
square root of two and for positive
initial conditions we wound up at
positive square root of two right and if
we were to look at all of them one
interesting thing is to note that at
exactly zero we end up with an an that
means somewhere it divided by zero and
that's not going to be an error in the
normal 64-bit floating-point arithmetic
if you divide by zero you'll end up
getting okay sorry you'll you end up
getting infinity if you divide by zero
but then if you start doing iteration if
you start doing operations with infinity
and 0 then you'll quickly get an an
alright so this is you know I Triple E
754 standard floating point arithmetic
rules
right so and we had you would ask the
time at macro so the the time macro will
tell us how long this takes
so one thing you will probably be
surprised you'll set you thought Julie
is supposed to be fast but if you take a
look at this this was only doing okay
what was this doing 110,000 iterations
and the number of allocations is a
little crazy
so this allocated over a gigabyte and
the reason for this is everything we've
been doing so far has been in global
scope so these have actually all been
global variables and in giulia it makes
a really big difference to performance
so a lot of times people will try Julia
out try porting some Python or MATLAB
code to Julia and run it and say this
was really slow and complained on the
mailing list or something and usually
the first thing that happened wrong is
everything was a global variable and the
reason julia is able to be fast but i'm
going to get into is inferring the types
of variables and compiling that to
efficient native machine code as if you
were writing in C or Fortran or a
compiled language right so if Julia is
able to figure out what the types of
everything are supposed to be and knows
that they're going to stay predictable
then it's able to a compile efficient
code transparently but if things are
global variables then you can't make any
guarantees because it's a dynamic
language you can change the value you
can't change the type of a global
variable right so I have write the
global variable a if I wanted to be an
integer and then I wanted to change its
type later to be a floating-point number
Julia lets you do that it lets you the
the value that you give to a can change
if it's global so you need to be able to
provide some guarantees that the type
doesn't change and do some analysis and
inference and this is sort of the
compilers job if you are writing in a
compiled language then to make the
compiler happy you would need to make
sure that things are declared types and
stay consistent types in a scripting
language an interpreted language the
interpreter would have to check every
time and say is this a floating-point
number
then do floating-point operations is
this an integer then do integer
operations and you know in Python
everything is a pie object so every
single operation that happens on it
needs to dispatch and do a potentially
different operation each time so that's
part of a lot of why you know you you
have you learned that for loops very
quickly and in python and matlab or slow
and you have to vectorize things and use
libraries like numpy so you're sort of
taught not to write Python code with
explicit for loops like this you're
taught to find a vectorized way of
expressing your operation or use a
library so the way around this which i
guess is not in this notebook but so
there's a very simple you put it in a
function right so earlier we had the
one-liner right earlier we were doing FX
equals x squared minus 2 whatever so the
longer form if it's not a one-liner
function as you spell it out so if it
had input arguments you would do our
Guan r2 etc but a zero argument function
just takes not no inputs so if you put
everything in a function and then if you
want it to return a value then you can
say return roots or the the return is
implicit in the last statement so the
last expression that gets evaluated if
you don't write return explicitly that
will be returned right so if I then do
and there you can see the allocations
were much smaller actually here this was
actually probably the allocations from
compiling this function so that was the
first time I ran it it had to compile it
and it just did that for you the second
time you run it you know ok
so the compiler overhead was not
actually
much I was expecting it to be more of a
difference but the the first time you
run something it will actually be
getting compiled and you'll be measuring
the compilation time but you can see how
much of a difference that made versus
versus this version right that was like
a 20 times difference and way more
allocations so here everything is a
global variable in the function form the
julia compiler is able to realize that
you've defined all of these as local
variables inside the function and it's
able to track and say did you change the
value did you change the type of these
variables within this function no you
didn't this state arranged great you
don't have to worry about it being
something else in the global variable
case you might change it later
so you need to be conservative okay so
right so this was 20,000 routes that I
just calculated so there's a lot of
different ways of plotting data in julia
nothing is built into the language by
default yet but there are a lot of
external packages so most commonly
people will use matplotlib in the Python
world and there's actually hopefully
I'll get to it there's a very very good
way of interfacing into Python libraries
from julia so if you have a lot of
Python code that you already use and you
want to sort of not have to rewrite all
of it
then Julia actually makes it pretty easy
to use your existing code and your
existing libraries through a package
called PI call and I'll show some
examples hopefully soon but one very
good example of existing Python
libraries and code that you might want
to use is matplotlib all right to plot
data so the the PI plot
Julia package is a julia interface to
matplotlib okay all right and just
showing right so I haven't done any
strings yet so in Julia you use the
double quote for string literals so
that's an ASCII string and I mentioned
earlier Unicode this is something that's
going to change in julia 0.4 ASCII and
Unicode strings were different types in
julia 0.5 now everything
is just going to be Unicode by default
but so the package manager is built into
the Giulia and you can use pkg ad to
install registered packages so there's a
list there's about a thousand a little
more than a thousand registered packages
that are available in Giulia right now
we need to come up with kind of a better
way of making these more discoverable so
you can figure out what's worth using
and what's unmaintained but the pkg
Giulia Lang org is just a dump
alphabetical listing with a little bit
of a summary there's also a page that
will sort of list what are they you know
which packages are being actively
updated which packages have the most
github stars what's trending what's
passing their tests and what isn't
so given you know I do a particular
Giulia package you might want like I
just told you about pie plot if you
don't have it installed already you do
pkg dot add PI plot and it takes a
minute it's built on the package manager
is built on git so all of these pretty
much all of the package repositories are
on github and you'll notice the when you
add a package it's actually cloning it
through get so if you're not comfortable
with doing get on the command line all
day you don't have to actually do that
so the package manager and Julia sort of
gives you it just wraps it wraps around
get for you so you don't have to worry
about all the particular invocations to
make it happy and do the right thing it
will just manage the versions for you
okay
it also manages you know you're not
always on master of these packages
you're using release tags and they have
inter they have inter dependencies and
requirements so there's a way that the
package manager knows what dependencies
the graph graphs package has or PI plot
has so for example pipe law
if you were to install it on julia box
for example then it's going to know it's
going to find out that these are all the
packages that pipe lot depends on right
so I mentioned particular Pike all right
so in order to interface with Python it
needs PI call and another set of
packages to do the plotting okay
so that's just that's an annoying error
message that will hopefully figure out
how to fix that wasn't supposed to
happen but anyway so I I have a whole
bunch of packages installed by default
they'll go into dot Julia directory
under your home folder and then under
the version of Julia that you're using I
have a whole bunch installed you can
also use pkg dot status is another way
so PKG dot status yeah
yeah
so okay so what that was doing so
remember how I had shown when you have a
really long array it'll skip it'll
truncate the display and won't show
absolutely everything so it will do that
as well for other collection types so
this will take a minute but so I have a
whole bunch of packages installed on my
machine and this will this has to read a
bunch of information from the disk which
is a little slow particularly because
I'm on Windows at the moment but that'll
what that's going to show PKG dot
installed gives is going to give you a
dictionary it's gonna be a hash table
from package name to package version so
it'll give you a list of however many
packages you have installed and from
string of the name to version number
type of the installed version and the
truncation is really just not displaying
at all but they're all there so you can
use i'll show you actually what since we
just mentioned them i'll show you what
hash table types look like that's a
useful type alright so i'm gonna say so
this is the syntax in julia for defining
a dictionary type a hash table alright
so you give it a set of pairs of keys to
values alright and then once I have that
I can access the values indexing with
the keys okay and you can iterate over
them as well so if I say what are the
keys of the dictionary D that'll give
you an iterator object and you'll notice
that the keys are not ordered in a hash
table so the order in which you get them
is not necessarily predictable
and the values will also give you an
iterator of the values right and you can
turn that into an array if you want with
collect but I wouldn't rely on what you
can't necessarily rely on the order so
so the package dot installed that's done
there it is yeah so so that was the
dictionary from string to version number
and let's say I think I have PI call
installed locally yeah right
and because windows kind of sucks at
unicode the dot dot dot is a funny
simple yeah so we're gonna try to
probably ship a better terminal emulator
that actually can do if you use a cygwin
or git bash those are better at unicode
and can actually show the characters
correctly okay all right so I had done I
had shown the difference between
defining a function in which you do
everything in which case julia is able
to know that these are local variables
and because it hit the end of the
function and you didn't change their
types it's able to compile efficient
code for them no okay I don't have that
many packages in still in the sequence
it's not but you'll have to trust me or
I could do actually I could do the V
dots nope bad font okay Unicode and
Windows okay so I had done I had added a
couple of these packages and you can do
using pipe lot so there's several
different ways there's well mostly two
so if you want to load a package you can
either do using the package or you can
do import the package now in Python it
would almost always be import and then
you in Python you do a lot oftentimes
you end up doing like you know
as right you do import numpy as some
short abbreviation we don't have the
aliasing yet in Julia but if you want to
look PI plot is a module so if you
really wanted to you could do that you
know and then you could do all of the
elements in PI plot but usually since
you know you can almost always do tab
completion the aliasing isn't too big a
deal
so using will take the exports of the
package which is that sort of the
definition of what are the public what
is the public API what are you supposed
to use and using will import those into
your namespace so those will you know
you'll now get a plot right so if I ask
where does plot come from right so plot
came from the PI plot package so we had
seen this before of generic functions
and methods so every function in julia
is generic over its input types because
values have types and in Julia you talk
about what the types of elements are are
you you can because it makes a big
difference to the compiled code you can
also define methods for the same generic
function and this happens a lot so let
me skip ahead a little bit yeah
so this happens even for the very basic
built-in arithmetic right so if I want
say the absolute value right the
absolute value of right negative five
right so that's just a built-in function
but there are many many many different
methods of the absolute value depending
on what input type you give it right so
each of these are defined in a different
location and you can in I Julie it'll
give you a nice little link and you can
see this is the julia source code that
defines the absolute value of a float64
input here this is actually kind of one
of the built-in operations this is the
interface to low level very low level
code this is a pretty primitive
operation but a lot of other things most
other things in julia like what you know
this isn't a public function but you can
see the definitions i mentioned that
two-thirds of the language is written in
julia you can open up the standard
library and see how everything is
implemented in julia code alright and
it's pretty simple to read so these are
all different methods for different
input types of the same function so
these are all part of absolute value
it's all called apps but depending on
what input type you call it on it
dispatches to a different method okay so
if you were to call the absolute value
of a diagonal matrix that's defined here
as a diagonal matrix of the absolute
value of the elements and on many many
many different input types
okay
so when I did using pipe lot if you ever
want to clear out if you want to reset
the current reset the value reset
everything that you've done the
workspace will clear things out and it
gives you a bunch of warnings but you
can ignore those so now if I just do
import then plot will not be defined
somewhere there we go so ignore the
warnings but undef variable because plot
is not defined because I did import PI
plot you have to do using PI plot to get
the plot method the plot function from
the package into your namespace there
and several a year or more ago it used
to take a very long time to load
packages but now packages get
automatically pre-compiled the first
time you use them and then the saved
compilation information Oh cache the
compiled code so the second time on that
you load a package will be much faster
in loading time yeah so if I'm going to
use pipe lot all right so I cleared my
workspace so of course I don't have
anything that we did earlier to find
all right
I even cleared of course I cleared F and
F and F Prime at the very beginning
there
so f prime and f
okay so now I have the 20001
roots that I calculated and we can plot
them
and we get it in line in the notebook if
you're using IGF if you're using the
standard terminal then I think this
would plop this would pop up in a
browser window I believe okay so yeah as
I described earlier
don't use global variables if you care
about what the performance is going to
be all right
so just by putting the function just by
putting the calculations in a function
they're no longer global variables and
the performance is much better this is
another thing here so in if you were to
refer to variables you actually don't
need them to be defined yet all right so
if I define f as the input times a but I
don't have an A yet if I try and call it
then it doesn't know what a is but it's
actually it let me do this definition
without complaining so it didn't
complain at compile time it only
complained when I tried to execute the
function at run time so that was a
runtime error and not a compile time
error in julia compile-time and run-time
kind of tend to blend together a little
bit but if I define a global variable a
now then I can call that function so you
have sort of late binding of global
variables
so this version here I was actually this
is returning multiple multiple values
alright so if I previously I was just
returning the results the roots but here
I'm saying both the initial conditions
and the roots so here this is equivalent
to doing a tuple of the return values
this is how Julia does this Julie
returns multiple values as a tuple but
you can leave the parentheses out and
it'll do the same thing you can even
leave the return out and it'll be
implicit so here this gives the tuple of
the first return and the tuple of the
second return and I could even you know
I could return I could assign those two
to different results then
right then a would be that first value
and B would be the array
that's interesting
oh I know why because I defined F I
redefine deaf I should have done that x
squared minus two there
so this was really so that was returning
a tuple of a float range in an array so
whose is a convenient way of getting all
of the names that are currently in your
namespace this is the packages that have
been loaded the modules that have been
loaded base is the standard library and
then all of the local variables and
functions that you've defined right we
had defined some of these arrays some
functions some ranges
okay
so what we've done so far wasn't
especially interesting we really weren't
doing anything interesting with the
inputs it wasn't very generic we just
tailored it to that specific case that
we were running we saw that if we then
redefined f it kept giving errors but
you could make a more generic function a
more generic version that would actually
take the function and the derivative
function the evaluation and the
derivative as inputs all right so this
is going to be much more generic now by
saying I'm going to do the Newton method
roots with the function and the
derivative provided externally now I can
use this on much on many more cases okay
so this now I've defined another method
so every function is generic and I've
given another method to this do roots
the first version that I did several
inputs ago took no inputs the second
input took two inputs okay so depending
on how many inputs I call it with it's
going to dispatch to a different version
of the implementation that I wrote for
the same generic function name okay so
now if I call this version with two
inputs and this is another one of those
things that is going to that we actually
fixed this was essentially a bug that
when you pass functions as inputs to
other functions Julia used to not be
able to optimize that very well but in
julia 0.5 which is coming out now ish
that is now fixed actually so this is
going to be much better for the
higher-order programming and passing
functions around and still getting high
performance code so you might not always
want to give functions names you might
want anonymous functions and the syntax
for doing that in julia is using the
arrow alright so I take the inputs to
the anonymous function and the value
that the anonymous function returns and
you can make it a multiple argument
anonymous function by doing a tuple of
the inputs right so a tuple of input
arguments two maps two kind of result of
the function so this is a very you know
convenient syntax I think in Python it's
a little bit more verbose you have to
like write out lambda could be worse it
could be Java but Julia makes it really
compact to do anonymous function
definitions just on one line right so
because we didn't actually annotate the
types here we just said we just gave
them names but we didn't give them types
so we could try to put in an integer
what's it gonna do so if I try and call
do routes of 1 and 2 so it is calling
this version with two arguments but this
error message at least on julia 0.4 it
got up to here and it tried to do tried
to call an integer as a function and it
said that i don't know how to call an
integer on a floating-point number and
that will also look a little different
but the error will be error would mean
the same thing as a consequence of the
way in which making anonymous function
and making functions as arguments fast
the way in which that in was implemented
means the error is gonna look a lot
different but you can't call an integer
as an object right it's not a callable
object you could define if you have your
own custom types you could define what
does it mean to call that type like for
example i can call right int is a type
but i can call int on if I call int on a
floating-point number right if I that
will try to convert right and give you
an exact number if it's exactly
convertible all right so this is what
calling if I do if I call an int then
that works right so if I call
- that's probably gonna give us also an
error but what is that gonna do so
that's gonna say it's actually probably
just identity I think if you call float
on an input that is already a
floating-point number it's just gonna be
the identity so that's not a very good
derivative so it's I think this is
nonsense it took yeah it took a thousand
iterations of subtracting one I think
which is not very exciting but yeah so
if you don't annotate the types of a
function then it can take anything but
it might not be meaningful so if I want
to say
it's both but to different extents so
both are faster now I think we did did I
delete that call already
oh here right so so you can see this
still allocated a bunch of memory and
usually that means it can't figure out
what the type is and it has to make it
any and do dynamic dispatch at every
iteration it's which means it just needs
to allocate a lot of memory for the
potential values it might contain it's a
boxed yes yes so this is the idea behind
dispatch so if you annotate the function
arguments the with a type right so I
could say right this wouldn't be very
meaningful but let's actually do
something more simple
so if I want to say a B equals any okay
then I want to call right so far okay
that was an e I haven't done anything
interesting
I only defined one method right so that
was just dispatching between the number
of input arguments but you can also
start saying new methods for specific
types okay so this called the generic a
because the input was an integer but if
you call it on a floating point it will
dispatch to the method that's defined
for floating point inputs and the idea
I've mentioned a few times of multiple
dispatch is you can do these in
arbitrary combinations
so that was any so you can start you can
see all the possible different
combinations you might define so saying
that you're doing the same generic
function the same verb but for many
different combinations of input types
and this actually ends up being really
convenient for sort of mathematical
operations on things that are sort of
like a number but have different
behavior depending on what particular
variation they are you can imagine the
particular implementation like I had
shown early on arbitrary-precision and
integers right if I want to add an
arbitrary if I want to add an arbitrary
precision integer to a floating-point
number that is going to look very
different in the way you implement that
then adding you know two floating-point
numbers together or doing some
calculation on on those input types if
you actually want to make it just if you
actually want to do the very low-level
right if it's a big integer if it needs
to call some library then I need to do
some C interfacing and you can imagine
that the method body is going to need to
be very different
right so so so annotating types is
actually does not make a difference for
performance annotating input types of
functions really only does dispatch so
that'll tell you which implementation to
call when the inputs are that
combination of types but the Julia
compiler already knows what types they
were so when you called the version
without any annotation right so if you
did the version with no func you didn't
talk about types at all when you call
that for a particular combination of
input types the Julia compiler will call
it will compile it for that combination
so the end result in terms of the
performance you get is not any different
so annotation is just for for dispatch
and potentially for documentation right
if this only you know this as we showed
this didn't actually make sense for
integers so we might want to annotate
this as saying hey this only makes sense
when F and F prime are functions and
then if that was the only method so do
routes annotated so then if I tried to
call that new that new version if I've
only defined a method for function
inputs if I try and call that on
integers it's gonna say I don't have a
method for do routes annotated on to
integer inputs so you might want to do
it for for sort of self documentation of
consistency that this code doesn't do
anything sensible for types other than
some subset but the performance is going
to be inferred by the compiler anyway so
the actual combinations of input types
that it gets called on is what it's
going to get compiled for okay so this
was walking through basically the same
thing right of you'll note at the if you
call you haven't talked about types at
all here but if you call it on an
integer versus you call it on a
floating-point it's actually going to
have to compile different methods it's
gonna have to compile different
implementations for taking the square of
an integer versus taking the square of a
floating-point number
those are gonna end up needing different
native code implementations you don't
have to see that but julia actually lets
you i might be skipping ahead a little
bit again but one thing that's very
interesting about julia is it lets you
see lets you ask the compiler what it's
doing so there's a couple of macros you
can use for this so here we had this H
of X is x squared so you can ask with
these macros code lowered this will sort
of give you a the internal
representation of what the julia
compiler represents that function call
as and this is kind of hard to read you
don't really need to is and it doesn't
actually just says return x square it
wasn't that interesting code typed will
be a little bit more interesting and
that will say ok i called it on an
integer right that's what i did
so here this was this did not have any
type information this was saying the X
input is any so I'm calling it on any
any any doesn't know any type
information code typed sees that you're
calling out on on integer three and
knows okay I'm calling it on an integer
then I can dispatch that x squared will
actually get transformed to x times X so
I think there's a inlining pass
somewhere in the julia compiler that
recognizes x squared is often more
efficient to recognize
replace with x times x so that's what
it's done here so it's done integer
multiplication of x times x which
returns an integer result when you call
h on an integer if you were to call it
on a floating-point number then it would
be floating point multiplication
so and the dispatch goes to the most
specific matching combination of types
right so if I did H X is x squared
without a type annotation but then HX
for float X is X cubed then you end up
getting very different results right so
this is something that you probably
don't either this could be pretty
confusing of getting very different
results whether something is an integer
or a floating point number even if they
have the same value sort of part of the
justification for dividing two integers
right we had you know that the Python
made that change between Python 2 and
Python 3
you probably want the behavior of
generic functions to be relatively
consistent otherwise it should probably
have a different name just for clarity's
sake okay so I think I had shown write
absolute value earlier complex numbers
syntax for doing that is I M built in as
the imaginary unit right so that oh geez
good ok so you can see that was of type
complex with integer elements but then
if I were to do write floating-point
then it's a different type
Yeah right so the ABS the ABS of a
complex number you can even see where
it's defined calls to hi pots which is
defined I think I think that calls into
Lib M you can actually see you can also
ask which so if I do the hi pop function
that I saw this calls it takes the high
pot of real and imaginary elements then
you can use this which macro to see okay
which particular method is gonna get
called there okay so here this is act
what this is actually saying is
promoting the types so in order to get
them to the same type so these
definitions are a little bit different
so this says X could be any real number
type Y could be any real number type but
real is what's called an abstract type
which is like a particular super type of
multiple other subtypes
alright so abstract types do not have
any values you cannot have a value that
is an abstract type an abstract type is
just a grouping of similar similarly
named concrete implementations so for
example you can ask there's a subtype
operator right that says integer is a
subtype of real and float floating point
is a subtype of real so the abstract
type real will take values of either
right so for Dispatch purposes any
subtype of real but they don't have to
be the same subtype so if I were to call
it with an integer and then a floating
point it would call this method but this
method here is saying
if X is of type T and Y is of type T
with the parametric constraint that T is
a floating-point number for both of the
inputs then it dispatches to this method
and this is a method x-ray okay so this
does not call it BAM this is actually in
Julia and saying the absolute value of X
the absolute value of y this is swapping
saying if X is smaller than Y then swap
them so that they're always sorted so
this is just a particular combination of
steps to to make sure you're avoiding
overflow you want to do things carefully
to avoid to get the right answer if one
of the elements is really really large
the naive way is just say square this
one square this one add them take the
square root but if that were to overflow
you get a nonsense answer so this is
just being careful about that case okay
right and so there are some function
some people things that people have
implemented to work around the fact that
anonymous functions were also a little
slow but if you start with Giulia 0.5
you don't have to worry about it okay
so what the results that we got couldn't
really see much from from that viewpoint
that zoom level but if I look between
one and three on the x-axis of where
thing we're interesting things are
happening you can see that function had
some interesting behavior okay all right
so I think the next step this goes into
is extending this to complex numbers
where Newton's method starts getting
more interesting it ends up with some
pretty pictures in the end this is
actually showing you that even
multiplication so even in fix operators
are actually generic functions so
they're just pretty syntax for calling
right
you can call multiplication as a
function if you want and it's gonna be
so the normal infix syntax is equivalent
for infix operators so even basic
operations like multiplication this is
telling you all the hundreds something
different specializations specialized
implementations of multiplication that
have been defined for all sorts of
different combinations of types in the
standard library and then if you were to
load you can see here at the end because
I've loaded a few extra packages then
packages will also start defining their
own types and like here there's color
types and this package has defined
multiplication between numbers and color
types so you would can be you commonly
want to extend the built-in functions on
types that you define in your own custom
code as data structures for whatever
custom operation you're doing okay
so I think let's actually go to speaking
of types
so there's two different you can either
make a mutable container composite type
or an immutable type in Julia so the
syntax for that is you name the type if
you want it to be a mutable container
type you can say type whatever the type
name is and then you give it fields
right so this would be field one this
would be field 2 so Julia the types and
the methods that are defined on them
live sort of separately it's not really
a conventional object-oriented language
like Python or C++ or Java where you
have classes that are that define both
the data structure and the behavior on
them with member functions in julia the
types are just the data structure and
the methods define verbs behaviors to do
to operate on them so you were you can
define types custom types and you can
also annotate the fields so if you want
to say the fields should have some
particular types then the syntax for
doing that is as follows right so that
would define
so that would define an immutable type
with one floating-point element or a
mutable type a composite type with three
out with three fields okay and by
default when you define a type it's
going to have constructors that are
defined for it by default that are gonna
sort of do the obvious thing so I just
said this is the data structure layout
and the kind of obvious things to do
with that are if I want to make one of
these I want to construct one the
default thing is it's actually just
going to say if you call it on something
and it had that one field right this the
vall was just wrapping a float64 and
it's just going to convert that to a
float64 if you try to call it on a
string it's gonna say i don't know how
to convert to a float64 from a string so
that won't work unless you were to
define a particular constructor if I
wanted to do that I could say I could
then define a define a type so there's a
define a method excuse me
so constructor methods to constitu
create a type our functions that have
the same name as the type itself so if I
want to say if I want to define a
constructor method to make one of these
objects from a string then I could say
the right so this is the syntax for
taking a string and parsing it into a
float 64 you do as you do here alright
so now that I've defined that now I can
call whoa I don't wanna do that
now that I've defined that method that
works alright alright so that was saying
the constructor for a string input which
was not one of the ones that was defined
by default the default constructors are
saying okay if you call it with the type
that it should be that's the easy case
and if you call it with anything else
it's gonna try to convert by default
which might fail as we showed earlier as
we showed when there wasn't a
specialized method if conversion failed
you weren't allowed to construct it here
yes so you can so there's a difference
between constructors that you define
outside the type and constructors that
you define at the definition time so
there there's inner constructors that
you define inside the type declaration
itself and you could say you can do
either declaration syntax with these
here you could say
right kind of can only constructs
all right so then if I were to that so
then the methods of that type
let's actually define it from scratch
let's define anyone just to be sure
right so this does not have the default
so that overrides was actually supposed
to go there that's why because I didn't
have the names matching there we go
so that was the inner constructor that I
just defined
so you can be you can be pickier if you
want in in the constructors that you
define okay so and since we declared
this as an immutable type you're not
allowed to mutate the fields right you
can't assign to the fields of an
immutable type they are construct once
and then you can't change them so this
is useful for allowing the compiler to
do cleverer things if it knows that
you're not going to be able to write new
values then it can actually turn field
access right if it if it's only ever
going to have the value that you assign
it at construction time then anytime you
look up this field element you can
actually you know that the value is
going to be the same which the compiler
can take advantage of all right and
there's several different syntax so you
can do V dot value or you can use get
field either by name or by index okay so
if yeah if you had used type then you
would be allowed to assign I think I had
shown
okay and now if I want to do m dot v1
and I want to change it to something
different and see what you can see that
it actually allows you to set the value
right so there anytime you were to look
up the value it actually has to look up
in memory to say where is that stored
and and get the value because it might
change over time but when you define
your custom types like this if every if
all of the fields have well-known
concrete types to them then julia is
actually able to optimize operations
like this very efficiently so types that
you define in your code as long as
they're structured in a way that the
compiler can reason about julia can
generate efficient code you're there's
no real difference between types that
are built into the language versus types
that you define in user code so I think
even even the built in types are
actually defined in julia and there's
nothing special about the julia code
that we wrote versus the julia code that
you write outside so like complex
numbers for example right I think
it's not supposed to be a link
there
right so even the built in complex
number this is saying that complex
numbers are a subtype of the abstract
number right so if you want it to be if
you want dispatch to work when something
is declared to be a number because a
complex number is a subtype of
arbitrary numbers you define it when you
define the type you declare it to be a
subtype of the abstract so you do you
can actually make your own you just do
abstract and then you can start defining
subtype relations anytime you declare
new types so that's just used for for
dispatch and then here this is
parametrizing to say that the real and
imaginary fields of a complex number
both have to be subtypes of real and
they have to be the same type T but this
is just Julia Code so complex numbers
are not special you could define them
yourself
right so something to avoid I said if
the types that the types of the fields
are something that Julia can reason
about it can generate efficient code but
if you don't annotate the types then
julia has no idea it's Annie right if
you don't give an annotation then it's
just equivalent to saying I don't know
anything about what type it was Annie is
an abstract type that contains anything
so then you could construct it with
anything right so if I write I can
construct objects with with no
constraints whatsoever but this is going
to be pretty bad for performance this is
basically going to be the same as if you
had global variables it's not going to
be able to optimize so here this is what
you actually want to do this says that
for any particular type of the value
field you put it in a type parameter and
this is making a family of types so this
is like templates in see for example
generic programming where you're
declaring that there the volume the
vault i p-- is parametrized over the
element type t so the built-in like
array types and complex types all do
this to say there is a different
distinct type layout right if you were
to have a complex number right or even
this this type that we just declared
right the parameters are going to be
different and the representation is
going to be different as well so when
when Julia when you do dot value here
it knows because the element type is
parameterize to be an integer the Julia
compiler is able to figure out that this
field access is always going to give you
an integer and this field access is
always going to give you a float
point where as if you had not declared
that type parameter then the it wouldn't
be able to say anything about the types
okay alright so this is what I had
mentioned with abstract types and
subtypes right integer and
floating-point or sub types of real
there's a arbitrary precision big float
type as well that you can use but
complex is not a subtype of real and
actually I think because subtyping does
not always work so complex numbers are
sort of a super type in the mathematical
sense of real numbers but the type
system in julia can't exactly represent
that constraint right the the real
numbers are complex numbers with
imaginary part exactly equal to zero but
that's not exactly what the subtyping
means in julia so you that's what number
was the fit was the was the parent of
both
so if you want to impose constraints on
the parameter then when you declare the
type parameter you say it must be a
subtype of a particular abstract type
and then if you were to declare it right
because string
right string is obviously not a subtype
of real number so if you've declared
that parametric restriction then you
can't convert from a string to anything
with the subtype of real okay and this
where you had been asking can you be
more picky about the types you can also
be more picky about the values right you
could say if you don't want to accept
negative numbers at construction time
then you can throw an error when you
construct the value although constraints
like this are harder to enforce for a
mutable type so if you were to do so you
could do a mutable type version of this
and that would be fine
it's not right
ah
because I didn't tell it there we go
so I actually needed to be needed to
tell it more specifically what I was
constructing so here it will throw that
error and say you know the the inner
constructor checked the value but it
won't check if I then change it all
right because this was mutable I could
then do right I could change it and make
it no longer satisfy the condition that
the constructor was trying to enforce
okay so you can then of course extend
you've declared these types you've
imposed a bunch of constraints on what
they're allowed to contain and what they
aren't you can start defining operations
on them arithmetic so if I've
constructed I don't know let's go back
to the simple one
nope I think I want the even simpler one
there we go
okay so if I construct two of these
types and I try and add them together
it's going to say I don't know how to
add two of these because you there's no
built-in definition for that okay so the
way to define that is you first import
the operator you need to do this to
extend addition otherwise if you try to
just say I'm going to define addition
parametrized over t to say that if I'm
adding two value two values that are of
this vowel type where the T parameter is
the same the value of that is a vol
wrapper of the value of the first one
plus the value of the second one right
so this will actually give you a warning
that if you try that okay so it will
work but you're supposed to actually
import it first right so in order to
extend I think if this wasn't at the
repple if this had been in a package it
wouldn't have worked at all without the
import so this is saying otherwise you
might be over writing - so if I was to
say so a module is like a namespace so
most packages are built as a module so
this is like a grouping a named grouping
of types and functions and constants so
and I want immutable vol
so if I did that it's going to give me
that same warning
okay well I was expecting it to give me
an error but it's but I'm not predicting
the way it's going to behave at the
moment
right okay
so if you've defined a method of the
generic function addition for that
combination of types then you can start
doing operations on it so I think I
don't have that much time left
I think this is supposed to end at 5 so
I'm actually should get into some more
like fun interoperability so we realize
that you're not going to rewrite all of
your code in Giulia you have a lot of
existing code there are a lot of
existing libraries out there
I showed briefly using matplotlib
through this PI call wrapper this is
doable in a lot more a lot more
interesting ways as well so you can call
into C libraries very very very easily
from Julia and this the way you do this
is very simple so there's a built-in
function called C call and what's the
way you call the way you use C call is
you give it the function you want to
call in the C library and then
potentially the library name right so if
this was the sign if I want to call the
C sine function then on a UNIX system
that would live in Lib M we actually
have a open Lib M that we use we build
it as a separate library so you give it
the function name and the library name
the return type a tuple of the input
types and here sine just takes a single
floating point and then you give it the
list of of inputs right so this was V
calling the C sign on the floating-point
number and you can do this for much more
interesting functions as well so you
this is actually how we define this is
how we define a lot of these operations
that are built on these libraries so I
have mentioned the big float is built on
this MPF our particular C library and
the way this is actually just calling
its using the C call function
and it's saying the function name is MP
fr underscore sine or cosine or tangent
in Lib MP fr it returns a status code
that we ignore so in in this particular
case it's a slightly more complicated
signature here it's saying I'm taking a
pointer to a big float object as the
output and the input and then a rounding
mode and I'm giving it a pre-allocated
output and a pointer to the input and
that's how we do sine and cosine of big
float types they're actually calling it
to the C library but because of this
wrapper code you don't have to worry
about how the C library works or what
you know what this signature is you
write at once and you can even do this
in a loop so here we're looping over all
of these function signatures a lot of
these C libraries happen to have very
sort of uniform copy/paste signatures
that appear they're very very closely
related to one another you can actually
use just generic Giulia code of I'm
gonna define these function signatures
using C call in a loop which makes it
much much simpler to wrap huge C
libraries when the API is really uniform
and this is actually what the PI call
library that I mentioned uses so the PI
call Julia package just invokes the
Python library to do the same thing that
the Python interpreter would on a block
of code so I'll show a cool example
right so if you've done
pkg dot add PI call and you do using PI
call it has some convenience macros so
it has a PI import and this sort of emit
this imitates the Python syntax so
macros that I didn't really have time to
go into but macros allow you to sort of
do arbitrary syntax manipulations by
manipulating the expression tree of the
Sinta of the julia syntax so it allows
you to sort of define
custom syntax extensions if you want so
size as Esso is not Julia syntax but the
at PI import macro knows how to read
that and does something special with it
so if you have Syfy installed and you do
PI imports I PI and then I call this is
me calling the Syfy Newton method from
on a Julia anonymous function with julia
values oh no oh no okay so this is going
to be exciting
yes yeah so there's a Julia there so
because Syfy and numpy and Jupiter and
everything are can be kind of hard to
install reliably without using Conda we
actually have a we used to have we used
to say manually install Conda first and
then point to it to use all these
matplotlib and Jupiter and Syfy and
everything so now we actually just wrap
it automatically and say we leverage
there we go that worked cool okay that
was easy
so yeah so this is me calling sigh PI's
Newton method on a Julia anonymous
function and you can see the result that
I get of cosine of that value minus
three times the value is pretty close to
zero of course this was pretty simple
you know Newton route-finding is very
simplistic there's if you're interested
in numerical optimization that's
actually an area in which Julia packages
are probably even better and more cut
more capable than the Python packages
for advanced problems that have
constraints and linear programming
nominee or programming it can talk your
ear about chalk your ear off about it if
you're interested but so that was a
simple example but you can extend this
and that's what the pipe lot package
uses the pipe law package is doing
importing numpy importing matplotlib and
putting julia wrappers around them and
PI import is wrapping with C call to
call into Python as a C library to do
the same thing that these Python
interpreter would do okay so I only have
five minutes left I think and that's
probably less time then you might have
questions for so all that people
hmm
yeah so there's a set of resources that
I think we have on the website I think
we have a learning page that has so
there have been a few books published
and there's also a good set of tutorials
so there's and of course the document
eight the standard documentation which I
when I first was looking into Julia I
actually found the manual to be more
readable than I thought it was going to
be and that's I guess just under under
the documentation so I I found the
manual relatively readable and easy to
get get going on I think you know as I
mentioned the fact that the language is
the fact that the standard library is
written in Julia means it's pretty easy
to find your way around and I think I
contributed my first patch to julia like
a handful of like a week or two after i
first ever used it so this is not
uncommon
so yeah either either the manual or sets
of tutorials that are there are
resources available
so it's getting there I mean it's not
1.0 yet you know where we're in release
candidates for 0.5 right now where it
will probably we will probably have a
1.0 release within the next year or two
but we do you know there are people who
are using it in you know its main it's
best for sort of local experimentation
kind of data science interactive type
tasks but there's really nothing
preventing you if you're adventurous and
if you want to try things out we've had
a lot of people just tell us that just
the productivity and performance gains
that they wound up getting by starting
to use julia really just outperformed
their previous systems by orders of
magnitude and they've it's taken over
you know that it's it's small but
growing
so I mean there are a few there is a wet
there is a giulio web organization that
has a set of packages for doing you know
HTTP servers HTTP requests WebSocket
interactions I think one of these is a
package for developing you know
deploying a julia application as an HTTP
api so these things are are out there
and a lot of like julia box that i
showed you is actually built on a lot of
these things so so they work you know
they're not quite as widely used as a
lot of like the core basic like linear
algebra type numpy Sai PI type features
they are right now in the standard
library that come by default but we're
working to sort of D couple things over
time and make it sort of make the core
language smaller in order to sort of
have a lot of other things out in
libraries make it more of a
general-purpose language you know Python
doesn't come with numpy by default a lot
of people use numpy all the time but
it's not really part of the language and
the way julia technically is is anything
that is written in julia code
technically could be in a different
repository it could be a package and
there's no real technical difference
so there's essentially any way that you
would that you would deploy any other
interpreted language scripting language
I think julia we something that will be
developed further over time would be pre
compiling like statically compiling
julia code into standalone executable
binaries right now there's not if that's
not an easy thing to do but
that kind of works like the standard
library is is a shared object it's it's
a little harder to do for your user code
but you know there is we build a DLL or
an Esso or a die Lib of the standard
library code packages right now we're
not the pre-compiled packages that I
mentioned are not native code yet but we
probably will make that work pretty soon
okay
well I think I'll be around for probably
the next couple days anyway if anyone
has any other questions or wants to know
I think so Thanks